este es el cuarto problema de los cinco
problemas que nos ha mandado cortar yo
que por cierto me han gustado muchísimo
y este problema me gusta mucho porque
además de tener toda la idea del álgebra
es decir en este problema vamos a
trabajar sistemas de ecuaciones con dos
variables tiene un conocimiento básico
de física y no sólo eso cuando uno lee
en principio estos problemas parece ser
que no tiene solución y después de
pensarlo un rato uno se da cuenta que
puede encontrar una solución bastante
divertida en este caso vamos a leer el
problema dice lo siguiente el tren a o
espera estoy aquí en otra alistar
perfecto en otra capa pero ya estoy en
la capa adecuada el tren ha representado
por esta flecha de verde ok tiene 200
metros de largo entonces vamos a ponerle
aquí que esto mide 200 metros 200 metros
ok el tren ve representado por esta
flecha tiene 400 metros de largo
ok ambos corren en rieles paralelos a
velocidades constantes es decir que
aunque vayan en direcciones contrarias
nunca van a chocar cuando ambos se
mueven a la misma dirección el tren pasa
al tren ve en 15 segundos de esta
configuración a esta configuración y
vamos a ponerlas eso es muy importante
cuando empezamos en esta configuración
es decir estar primero el tren a que es
justo este que por cierto sabemos que
mide 200 metros ok y después está el
tren ve que es este de aquí aquí tenemos
al tren ve que mide 400 metros va a ser
este de aquí y mide 400 metros ok
logramos pasar de esta configuración
cuando el tren a está atrás justo atrás
del tren va a llegar a que el tren me
quede justo atrás del tren es decir el
tren a alcance y rebase al tren me va a
quedar aquí el tren ven y aquí va a
quedar mi tren a mi tren que es 200
metros cuando pasa esto para pasar de
esta configuración a esta configuración
se necesitan 15 segundos eso es muy
importante se necesitan 15 segundos por
lo tanto de esta configuración a esta
configuración pasan 15 segundos 15
segundos ok ahora dice cuando ambos se
mueven en direcciones contrarias ellos
se cruzan completamente en 5 segundos es
decir pasan de esta configuración a esta
configuración vamos a poner las pasamos
ahora de esta configuración en donde
están viendo frente a frente aquí tengo
el tren a que es de 200 metros que está
viendo al tren ve a este tren ve que es
de 400 metros 400 pero que fue 4
400 metros 400 metros ok pasan de esta
configuración a una configuración en
donde aquí tengo al tren ve que es 400
metros 400 metros y después se van a
pegar en la parte trasera se van a pegar
justo aquí y ahora por aquí tengo al 30
que mide 200 metros ok
y esto esto le toma 5 segundos en que
pase de una configuración a la otra
justo aquí dice eso en cinco segundos
cambian de configuración entonces como
van en direcciones contrarias es más
rápido y esto se desarrolla en cinco
segundos en cinco segundos de lujo cuál
es la velocidad de cada tren dada en
metros sobre segundos ok ahora la clave
de este problema la clave de este
problema está en pensar lo siguiente
pero es que si nos fijamos el problema
dice que se mueven a velocidades
constantes a velocidades constantes y
son muy importantes su velocidad no va a
cambiar a lo largo del problema y por lo
tanto si nosotros bautizamos a la
velocidad de este tren del tren a como
la velocidad del tren a originales y si
nosotros bautizamos a la velocidad de
este tren ve como la velocidad del tren
ve ok y vamos a ponerlo también aquí la
velocidad del tren ve
y aquí la velocidad del tren a la
velocidad del tren
de lujo ahora una vez que ya sabemos
cómo se llame las velocidades y si
nosotros recordamos la gran fórmula que
nos dice que la distancia y déjame
ponerlo con otro color la distancia es
lo mismo que la velocidad por el tiempo
ok ya que recordamos esta fórmula de la
física entonces vamos a intentar
resolver este problema usando esta
fórmula que tengo aquí pero lo
importante es que hablemos y nos fijemos
en qué es lo que pasa con las distancias
relativas y con la velocidad relativa
relativo al tren b es decir qué tan
lejos está viajando el tren a relativo
al tren si ustedes nos fijamos por
ejemplo en este punto del tren am si te
das cuenta lo que hace el tren a
relativo al tren b es caminar esta
cierta distancia ok y después esta otra
cierta distancia porque llegamos hasta
la punta del tren
y si te das cuenta toda esta distancia
son 600 metros 600 metros es decir que
si nos fijamos en la distancia que
recorre el tren up relativo al tren b
son 600 metros y bueno tal vez el tren
recorre a más distancia vaya a una
cierta velocidad y el tren ve
recordándose 100 metros bueno si el tren
ver recorre 100 metros el tren va a
recorrer 600 más los 100 metros que
recorrió el tren ve por lo tanto sigue
recorriendo 600 metros relativo al tren
ve ahora pensemos qué es lo que pasa
aquí si lo pongo justo aquí justo aquí
en donde está la parte frontal del tren
am bueno pues yo empiezo el recorrido
aquí la comparación más bien relativo al
tren ven ya cabo un recorrido hasta acá
otra vez hasta acá está la parte frontal
de este tren a por lo tanto también
recorrido 600 metros también recorrió
600 metros el tren relativo al tren ven
qué tan lejos se ha viajado el tren al
relativo el tren ve bueno en ambos casos
es 600 metros solamente que en este caso
el tren pesado sus viajes su recorrido
en la parte trasera del tren ve y en
este caso ha empezado su recorrido en la
parte delantera del tren ver ahora en
este caso la velocidad tiende a depender
de la velocidad debe pero es devorada
por la velocidad debe y eso es muy
importante porque si la velocidad debe
es por ejemplo 100 metros sobre segundos
imagínate que la velocidad debe fuera
estática la velocidad del tren lo que
hace es superar al tren b y después
recorrer estos 600 metros de igual
manera aquí si la velocidad del tren vez
fuera cero metros lo que pasaría es que
este tren cruzaría al tren ve ahora si
la velocidad del tren ve fuera cualquier
velocidad que a ti se te ocurra el tren
nada siempre va a ir más rápido de tal
manera que va a llegar el punto en el
que lo va a rebasar y va a lograr
ponerse enfrente de él mientras que aquí
va a pasar justo lo que queremos el tren
a tiene una cierta velocidad que va a
ser más grande que la bebé y por lo
tanto en un tiempo menor el tren va a
llegar de esta configuración a esta
configuración ahora recordando la
fórmula que tenemos aquí la fórmula lo
que nos dice es que la distancia que en
este caso son 600 metros relativo al
tren ven y en este caso también son 600
metros relativo al tren ven es igual a
la velocidad y justo ahorita vamos a
hablar de la velocidad a por el tiempo
el tiempo en este caso son 15 segundos y
en este caso son 5 segundos ahora que
producidas buscamos bueno si te das
cuenta supongamos que nosotros nos
ponemos aquí vamos a poner aquí a un
pasajero que esté en el tren ve
supongamos que lo pongo justo aquí aquí
tengo a un pasajero del tren ven bueno
si me fijo en este pasajero del tren ve
y relativo a él voy viendo qué velocidad
toma el tren al acercarse pues me voy a
dar cuenta que el tren al acercarse toma
una velocidad de vea de la velocidad del
tren a menos la velocidad del tren ve y
bueno esto tiene toda la lógica del
mundo porque el tren a se está acercando
al tren ve no el tren bien por otra
parte se está alejando del tren a por lo
tanto el tren a se está acercando al
tren ven con la diferencia de
velocidades
y si esto lo multiplicamos por los 15
segundos que tengo aquí ok por los 15
segundos y bueno estos tarda unos
segundos esto tendría que ser
exactamente igual a la distancia que son
600 metros y qué creés hemos encontrado
la primera ecuación la diferencia de
estas dos velocidades y esto es porque
el tren vez se aleja del tren am
mientras que la se acerca al tren ven ok
por el tiempo tiene que ser igual la
distancia ahora pensemos en este caso si
yo pongo ahora a mi persona que estaba
en el tren b lo voy a poner justo aquí
ok más o menos así y bueno aquí parece
que los brazos los tiene alzados porque
está gritando por tanta velocidad o en
dado caso los brazos les salen de la
cabeza pero supongamos que pongo a mi
persona relativa justo ahí ok
qué tan rápido se acerca el tren a al
tren b y bueno pues el tren se está
acercando a una velocidad de vea de su
propia velocidad más la velocidad del
tren ve porque si te das cuenta van al
mismo punto van en sentidos contrarios
el tren se está acercando el tren ve
bien está y también se está acercando el
tren am por lo tanto la velocidad
relativa a esta persona que está en el
tren ve es la velocidad más la velocidad
ven y bueno si a esto lo multiplicamos
por el tiempo que son cinco segundos
déjame ponerlo si a esto lo
multiplicamos por el tiempo que son
cinco segundos esto tiene que ser igual
a la distancia que sabemos que son 600
metros que sabemos que son 600 metros y
de lujo si te das cuenta aquí ya tengo
dos ecuaciones tengo esta ecuación de
aquí esta ecuación de aquí o que que
tiene que ver con las dos velocidades
que es justo lo que busco y esta
ecuación de aquí que tienen que ver con
justo a las dos velocidades que son las
que busco y todo gracias a las
velocidades relativas a las distancias
relativas ya estas dos personas que nos
han ayudado bastante a entender el
problema ahora qué te parece si
resolvemos este sistema de ecuaciones
con estas dos incógnitas para eso
déjenme bajar un poco la pantalla ok
voy a distribuir primero la
multiplicación de esto es más creo que
primero voy a dividir todo entre 15 y
voy a dividir todo entre 5 de esta parte
qué pasa si divido todo entre 15 bueno
pues me va a quedar que vean vea menos
bebé ok la velocidad del tren a menos la
velocidad del tren ven es exactamente lo
mismo que 600 entre 15 y cuántos
seiscientos entre 15 vamos a hacerlo
aquí 600 entre 15 bueno pues esto es lo
mismo que 44 por 5 es 20 llevamos 24 por
14 y 2 son 6 60 60 menos 60 es 0 bajo un
cero y pongo el cero entonces me queda
40 15 por 40 y 600 por lo tanto aquí
tengo 40 ok y de este lado de este lado
me queda que la velocidad del tren más
la velocidad del tren ve esto va a ser
igual a 600 entre 5 cuántos 600 en 35
bueno pues si lo hacemos aquí 600 entre
5 esto es exactamente lo mismo que 1
a sombra 10 210 000 120
120 ok ya tengo otras ecuaciones mucho
más fáciles y de hecho ya tengo dos
ecuaciones que se pueden sumar y
eliminamos a la variable la velocidad
del tren vez es decir que si aquí pongo
vea más bebé igual a 120 estoy poniendo
las dos ecuaciones una abajo de la otra
y la sumo voy a sumar esta y voy a sumar
esta estos dos se van que es justo lo
que yo quería y tradujo me queda
solamente que dos veces la velocidad del
tren a am es lo mismo que 40 más 120 lo
cual son
160 160 ok y si aquí despejó y la
velocidad del tren am bueno pues esto es
lo mismo que 160 entre 2 lo cual es 80
80 metros sobre el segundo porque
recuerda que estas unas unidades el
tiempo está dado en segundos las
distancias tardarán metros por lo tanto
la velocidad del tren a 180 metros sobre
segundo de lujo ya la encontré que es
justo lo que quería ahora de aquí puedo
a la velocidad del tren ve de esta
ecuación o de esta ecuación vamos a
sustituirla en esta ecuación de aquí 80
que es la velocidad del tren a 80 metros
sobre segundo más la velocidad del tren
ven esto tiene que ser igual a 120 ok y
por lo tanto la velocidad del tren ver
tiene que ser igual a 120 menos 80 lo
cual son 40 40 metros sobre segundo y de
lujo ya tengo ambas velocidades que es
justo lo que quería la velocidad déjame
ponerlo con este color la velocidad del
tren a us 180 metros sobre segundo del
lujo la velocidad del tren a mientras
que la velocidad del tren son 40 metros
sobre segundo estás de lujo de hecho el
tren va al doble de velocidad que lo que
va el tren ve del lujo pues vamos a
subir un poco la pantalla vamos a subir
un poco la pantalla vamos a subirla y
bueno recordando que todo esto fue
gracias a que nosotros nos fijamos en
estos dos tipos en este tipo de aquí y
en este tipo de aquí y todo lo hicimos
relativo a ellos dos entonces ahora
podemos decir que en este primer caso el
tren am
a una velocidad de 80 metros sobre
segundo ok en esta dirección mientras
que en la misma dirección va el tren ve
a 40 a 40 metros sobre segundo ok esto
no parece un 4 déjame ver si lo puedo
quitar ok quitemos lo y vamos a poner un
4 que se parezca 4 ok y en el segundo
caso en el segundo caso tengo que el
tren a va a una velocidad de 80 metros
sobre segundo pero en esta dirección
mientras que el tren bbva a una
velocidad de 40 metros sobre segundo en
esta dirección y bueno todo esto gracias
a cortar yo que nos mandó sus problemas
que por cierto nos han gustado bastante
y nos han mantenido bastante
entretenidos hasta luego